Regarding the intentions, still on the
intentions issue, does one always have
to make intentions regarding when you're
about to fast and secondly
the timing of the intentions. Can you
just say something a little bit about
that?
As far as the intention is concerned, as
I mentioned earlier, that intention is a
and our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it's mentioned in
sunai book of fasting had number 2331.
Our beloved prophet said a person fast
not accepted if he does not make
intention in the previous night. That
means for all the further fasting
compulsory fasting making intention the
previous night is compulsory. It can be
any part of the previous night. It can
even be till as late as just before the
fud time. Any time of the night you can
make intention. A person can make an
intention in the beginning of Ramadan
and it can be valid for the full month
of Ramadan unless he breaks it if he's
sick or if he's traveling then he has to
again make intention but one intention
is also sufficient and many people think
they have a misconception that verbally
saying it aloud is a must which is not a
requirement I don't have to say verbally
that I intend to fast because my
intention is a nia from the heart for
example if I get up late in the night
much before fudger time for fasting.
Suppose my son
when we have got up to do a suhur late
in the night and my son asks me that why
have you got up? I will tell him because
we have to fast. So it's already
understood the nia is there. I don't
have to say that I've got up too fast.
Mhm.
The nia is there. So nia is important.
Nia is in the heart. You don't have to
say it with your tongue. That's what
most of the people think. And I don't
know of any hadith which says that the
prophet or the Sabbath ever said loudly
that I intend to fast. Intention is in
the heart and one intention is
sufficient for the full month of Ramadan
unless as I said it's broken. But this
is only for the fur fast for a voluntary
fast which is not a fur fast. Intention
is not a because there's hadith again
mentioned in sunai in the book of
fasting hadith number 2323
one is the prophet he tells his wife
that I want food to eat and the wife
said that there's no food to eat so he
said okay I'm fasting that means his
intention was not there before in the
previous night he made it on the spot he
abstained from before dawn but his
intention was afterwards in the morning.
So for the voluntary fast it's not
compulsive to be made early the previous
except if it is a very important
voluntary fast like the Ashurah the 10th
of Maharam Ashur or it can be the day of
Arafat it's preferable to make intention
before because that's very important
fast for all the other voluntary fast
it's not compressible made before
previous night for the nia there are
other three things which are very
important one thing if it's by force and
if something is broken then it can be
forgiven or by error or by
forgetfulness. As Allah says in the
Quran in surah nahel chapter number 16
verse number 106 that after a person has
believed
then if he does something of unbelief
does something of kuf except by force
that mean if he does by force even kuf
or shik Allah will forgive so if someone
forces a person to break the fast his ny
was in there he can be forgiven and
Allah says in surah bakar chapter number
two verse number 286 Six that oh Lord
please do not catch us please do not
hold us responsible when we er when we
make a mistake or when we forget. So if
a person in his forgetfulness breaks his
fast like has water, Allah will forgive
him. Or if because of a mistake, Allah
will forgive which we shall deal later
inshallah.